[Musique]
bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro du 7-8
loisirs tout de suite le sommaire de ce
vendredi de mars opus 2018 de la voie de
l'écuyer de l'académie équestre de
versailles
les écuyers leurs montures ont repris
les représentations après une pause
hivernale
nous recevrons cécile berthelot
administratrice de l'académie pour nous
parler de ce spectacle entre art
limitation le froid s'est bien installée
mais les beaux jours reviennent bientôt
plus que quelques semaines avant le
retour du printemps et l'association
jardins passions partage se prépare
plusieurs rendez vous sont organisés
pour le public la présidente de
l'association nouvelle nous a ouvert ses
portes et fait découvrir son jardin une
activité sportive et non à un atelier
manuel ce week end mais les peintures et
sciences la commanderie des templiers ou
mettez vous dans la peau d'un pilote de
course au circuit beltoise
le point avec mélanie poquet sur les
activités du week end réservé aux plus
jeunes
mais avant du sport ce dimanche
s'élancera la 76e édition du paris-nice
c'est la neuvième année consécutive que
la course au soleil par des yvelines
plus 250 coureurs prendront le départ à
chatou pour la première étape 135 km à
travers le département avant de
rejoindre les hauts-de-seine à saint
quentin en yvelines les communes de
villepreux même les hameaux voisins et
montigny le bretonneux sont concernés un
rendez vous a pas mon type tous les
amateurs immersion au coeur de la
culture urbaine à plaisir jusqu'au 11
avril le festival scènes urbaines
revient pour une deuxième édition la
ville et l'association une cypher nous
font découvrir la diversité des
disciplines du mouvement hip hop une
exposition est actuellement visible à la
clé des champs il s'agit de l'artiste in
her originaire des yvelines
un style qui figeait l'univers de la bd
et street art sur des toiles du mobilier
ou des objets le 10 mars un concours
chorégraphique est organisé un jury
élira le meilleur show parmi différentes
compagnies de danse et peuple d'île de
france sandrine dilemne membres du
collectif unicef leur organise
cet événement en fait à la base nous on
a créé une saveur parce que on s'est
rendu compte qu'on était il ya beaucoup
de talent dans les yvelines
on se rencontrait à des éléments des
concours chorégraphique ou de battles
mais pas forcément ici et en fait on
s'est dit c'est un peu dommage de perdre
autant de chemin pour qu'on se croise la
bam ce temps faire un truc chez nous où
il ya déjà d'autres assauts dans les
yvelines qui font plein de battles et on
s'est dit pourquoi pas lancer un
concours chorégraphique comme ça voilà
les groupes qui proposent des shows on
fait ça on fait ça ici après un repos
hivernal l'académie équestre de
versailles a rouvert ses portes
les écuyers et leurs montures ont repris
le chemin du manège pour leur spectacle
répertoire la voie de l'écuyer avec nous
ses cils berthelot administratrice de
l'académie pour nous parler de ce nouvel
opus 2018 bonjour bonjour alors ce
spectacle il a une histoire il a été
créé en 2003 par le chorégraphe bartabas
date aussi de création de l'académie
justement oui tout à fait l'académie est
installé à versailles donc depuis 2003
et depuis donc cette époque l'académie
donne à voir au public son spectacle de
répertoire qui s'appelle la voie de
l'écuyer et qui est le reflet de ce qui
se passe au quotidien à l'académie c'est
le reflet en fait de tous les
apprentissages de nos écuyers à l'ordre
aux apprentissages justement ce
spectacle a été enrichie de différentes
disciplines en au fil au fil des années
notamment de l'escrim du chant ou du
quiou de kyudo kyudo je sois trop en
asie l'étudiant en effet c'est du tir à
l'arc japonais qui est un art martial
qui qui est à la fois basée sur la
concentration et la méditation qui sont
deux atouts absolument indispensable aux
écuyer pour leur travail avec le cheval
donc c'est en complément de leurs de
leurs cours de dressage et c'est vrai
qu'en fait le
l'opus s'est enrichie au fil du temps de
tous les apports artistique que les
écuyers ont pu recevoir et notamment
s'est enrichie aussi des créations
faites à l'extérieur de l'académie c'est
notamment le cas d'un tableau de danse
que l'on voit à la fin du spectacle avec
les rênes à la ceinture et donc ce
tableau est venue après une
collaboration avec la chorégraphe
carolyn carlson en 2011
pareil pour le chant c'est au fil du
temps que les écuyers ont travaillé leur
voix et donc le champ a fait son
apparition dans le spectacle au fil des
collaborations en fait on parlait du
kyudo tout à l'heure on l'a vu justement
à l'instant à l'image et je le disais en
titre justement l'originalité de cette
création c'est de proposer un spectacle
à mi-chemin entre harare et équitation
c'était assez naturel comme proposition
comme comme création oui tout à fait ça
fait vraiment partie en fait de la
volonté de bartabas qui pour lui en fait
un écuyer pour que sa formation soit
complète ne doit pas s'intéresser peu
aux chevalets le dressage est en fait
toutes ces disciplines artistiques
viennent enrichir le savoir-faire des
écuyers et leur permet en fait de
l'appréhender aussi leur travail d'une
autre manière
c'est vraiment un tout en fait et la
relation homme homme cheval est très
fort mais femmes d'ailleurs en est très
importante avec l'animal c'est essentiel
pour arriver justement à ce résultat
oui c'est vraiment à
le coeur en fête de de la réussite de
dix métiers d'écuyer d'artistes écuyers
c'est d'abord la relation qui le
développe avec leur cheval et il peut
faire un parallèle aussi parce que ce
qu'un musicien vit avec son instrument
le cheval devient le prolongement de
de l'écuyer qui le montrent au même
titre que le violon devient le
prolongement du bras du violoniste
alors justement la formation pour
arriver à ce résultat est très exigeante
comment ça s'organise quotidiennement ce
travail des écuyers avec leur monture
alors les écuyers effectivement des
journées bien remplies
puis ce qu'ils ont à peu près quatre à
cinq chevaux à travailler chaque jour
donc c'est du travail soient montées
soit du travail aux longues rênes soit
du travail à pied
tout dépend de de ce qu'ont fait les
chevaux aussi dans les jours précédents
et puis donc il ya aussi toutes ces
disciplines artistiques qu'ils reçoivent
chaque semaine donc
une heure de chorales par semaine une
heure de cours de chant individuel une
heure de danse
leonard escrime aussi donc voilà c'est
tout ça est articulée sur la semaine
donc c'est un bon comment dire un bon
mix entre entre du travail équestre et
du travail artistique et donc l'opus
2018 est maintenant à découvrir quelles
nouveautés on enrichit le spectacle
cette année alors on a
on a des jeunes recrues écuyère donc qui
ont intégré le l'opus donc c'est ce sont
deux élèves qui étaient en appelant club
suisse de préformation l'année dernière
et qui donc maintenant intégré des
tableaux du spectacle
l'une d'entre elles a participé pour la
première fois au est ce qu'on appelle le
carrousel qui est le tableau un petit
peu emblématique de l'académie elle a
fait sa première apparition en carrousel
à l'occasion de la réouverture
voilà et c'est important d'ailleurs de
rappeler qu'on recrute chaque année de
nouveaux élèves en préformation et que
d'ailleurs la semaine prochaine on
organise une journée portes ouvertes à
destination de futurs élèves et que
juillet le 9 mars
avis aux amateurs en tout cas la fin
d'entretien mais le message est passé
donc vendre vendre du 9 mars à bien sa
journée portes ouvertes pour ceux qui
souhaitent intégrer l'académie et xavier
plus généralement il ya également des
visites
des coulisses avec les des mines qui
peuvent se faire en compagnie d'un guide
merci beaucoup en tout cas que nous
n'oubliez pas que le spectacle la voie
de l'écuyer opus 2018 est donc à
découvrir à l'académie équestre de
versailles
l'ensemble des dates de représentations
est disponible sur le site internet
si le froid frappe le département les
beaux jours eux sont déjà presque là
avec ces températures sibériennes
direction le jardin pour le préparer au
retour de la belle saison
hank de faux présidente de l'association
jardins passions partage de guyancourt
nous a ouvert les portes de son jardin
d'éden images de nicolas landry ce sas
assure des voiles d'hivernage
on les cours pour réchauffer un peu la
terre pour préparer la culture comme ça
pendant pendant trois semaines ou un
mois ça réchauffe un peu la terre malgré
le froid à l'intérieur ça fait un peu
chaud mais après ça va activer la levée
des semis dans quelques semaines
carottes et poireaux seront plantés dans
ces bacs de permaculture une technique
de jardinage bien particulière qui
permet d'économiser l'eau grâce à
différentes couches de terre
c'est grâce à l'humidité qui retiennent
au fond de la deûle à de la butte
on a mis des branches d
eni composent saradar l'humidité et en
plus ça décompose l'économie d'eau et de
travail aussi parce que comme ça on a
moins à désherber moins arrosées et ça
pousse beaucoup mieux présidente d'une
association de jardinage à guyancourt
hank de fo est une véritable passionnée
elle fait régulièrement découvrir son
jardin et donne ses conseils aux
visiteurs
malgré le froid hivernal elle se prépare
déjà au retour des beaux jours la terre
est très émue et pas trop froid c'est
presque bon pour pour faire du sommet en
attendant la jardinière surveille ses
protégés qui ont passé l'hiver dans
leurs cabanes et celles à faire ben là
il ya des foyers qui sont il faut il
faut les tailler un travail régulier
partagé depuis quatre ans avec son
association
de nombreux ateliers sont organisés pour
apprendre à avoir la main verte
les prochains rendez-vous ce 3 mars à 14
heures à voisins le bretonneux avec une
séance de taille fruitière le 10 mars
également un atelier d tox de printemps
pour découvrir comment prendre en charge
sa santé par les plantes
l'inscription est obligatoire c'est le
moment de passer à notre rendez-vous
junior mélanie nous a préparé un
programme pour ce week end
[Musique]
mélanie nous a donc rejoint en plateau
vous avez deux activités à proposer un
atelier manuel eme journée sportive
c'est ça alors plusieurs sortes de
talents vont être mis à profit ce
week-end pour la première vous allez
pouvoir mais les peintures et sciences
la commanderie des templiers fait de la
peinture connecter ce samedi grâce à des
peintures conductrice vous allez donner
vie à vos descend les rendant lumineux
et sonores c'est le pot dernier atelier
autour de l'image et du son
l'exposition perception illusions se
termine ce week-end alors l'atelier dure
une heure et s'adresse aux enfants à
partir de 6 ans l'entrée est libre mais
c'est sur réservation et donc sur les
relations donc le bandeau qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran pour pouvoir
s'inscrire et pour ceux qui voudraient
terminé ses vacances d'hiver en
extérieur la vitesse va être de mise du
côté de trappes
alors c'est fini de jouer avec au pilote
de course sur sa voiture à pédales ou
pourquoi pas comme je le faisais enfants
avec l'aspirateur de mes parents on
passe aux choses sérieuses sur le
circuit jean-pierre beltoise de trappes
avec le formula kids l'école de pilotage
ce dimanche c'est à dire le 4 mars les
jeunes de 7 à 18 ans vont pouvoir
prendre une leçon de conduite sur de
vraies voitures de sport pour les plus
jeunes c'est jusqu'à 12 ans ce sera au
volant d'une smart roadster et les plus
grands eux pourront même tester une
porsche boxster
regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc les initiations qui dure une heure
et demie le site internet pour pouvoir
s'inscrire s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci beaucoup mes amis pour ses idées
sorties l'heure environ 3 plutôt faire
de la peinture ou sur circuit ce week
end circuit et paris nice comme ça on
retrouvera là-bas alors merci en tout
cas pour saisi les sorties dédié aux
plus jeunes
c'est la fin de cette 8e loisirs merci
de nous avoir suivi on se retrouvant
dans les prochain pour un nouveau numéro
et d'ici là je vous souhaite un
excellent week end
où
m
oh